Ciao Gu ciao ospite, la mia domanda è una
domanda che risale almeno all'antica
Grecia, se non addirittura ai dinosauri, ed è
Può esistere l'amicizia tra ex? Si! Dipende
tantissimo come vi siete lasciati
Certo! E dipende anche tantissimo secondo
me dai motivi per cui vi siete lasciati
Se vi siete lasciati per vari motivi ma
tra questi non c'è il fatto che non
foste più attratti l'uno dall'altra,
allora è già più difficile secondo me
Capito cosa intendo? Certo. C'è anche un pezzo in Jurassic park in cui proprio due t rex
stanno così. Non sei troppo fuori tu? Sì, cioè
voglio, perché sono un artista generoso. Ah ok
E comunque già il fatto che tu lo
chiedessi, vuol dire che sotto sotto ti
aspettavi che la risposta e speravi che
fosse no. L'hai capita pure tu? Certo. Eh biricchina...
Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Vita Buttata. Il tema della
puntata di oggi è "La posta del cuore
parte 2"
Ci siamo presi una pausa, perché
veramente stavamo facendo una roba
infinita e siamo tornati, quindi direi a
questo punto di metterci ad ascoltare i
messaggi e vedere un pochino che cosa
hanno da dirci. Ciao Gu ciao ospite chiunque
tu sia. Per la posta del cuore potresti darmi
un consiglio su come far lasciare te e il tuo
ragazzo, perché ho una cotta per Luigi ed
è troppo bello, cioè anche tu sei molto bello però
Luigi ancora di più, grazie.
E niente, grazie in anticipo. Possiamo
vedere il profilo di questo ragazzo?
Andiamo a vedere il profilo di questo ragazzo
che magari mi fai un favore e me lo toglie dalle p***e.
Carne fresca, non vuoi il prosciutto
stagionato ok? Grazie il prossimo. Grazie mille
Si, perché non si sveglia vicino a te ogni mattina
Tiè, tiè. Io sono felicemente innamorata del mio miglior amico, ovviamente gay, da una cosa come
quattro anni? Cioè è un bono della Madonna,
veramente, sia dentro che fuori. Cioè è perfetto
Di conseguenza so che me ne devo fare una ragione ma non ci riesco. Che cavolo fò? Farti una ragione?
Trovare un chiodo che non sia interessato ad altri
chiodi che schiacci il chiodo che è
interessato ad altri chiodi? Nella vita
chiodo schiaccia chiodo, in questo caso
stai cercando di martellare un chiodo
interessato a troppi chiodi, quindi trovane
uno interessato al tuo quadro o quello che è.
I vostri amici gay non li cambiate
E' parecchio dura. E' tosta.
Anzi anche per loro è tosta, poi cercare
di svincolarsi e farvi capire, intendere
bene, metteteli nella condizione di
tranquillità.
Fategli tanti complimenti che loro
che a noi piace sempre insomma il complimentino facile e...
Ti faccio risentire il messaggio del tizio prima? Dai!
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite,
ogni tanto io penso di aver provato
tutto quello che posso provare e tutte
le relazioni che avrò da adesso in poi
saranno tutte una versione inferiore di
quello che ho effettivamente già provato
Esco da una situazione di cinque anni
con il mio migliore amico, che è finita
in un modo abbastanza brutto. Per me non
c'era niente che non andava in quella
relazione e quindi mi chiedo se riuscirò
a riavere mai lo stesso livello di
confidenza con un'altra persona. Grazie.
Questo messaggio un pochino mi spacca
il cuore devo essere sincero. Stai per dire
qualcosa? No stavo cercando i pezzetti del
tuo cuoricino. Trovare una persona che ti
fa innamorare, fa perdere la testa in
maniera così potente da farti mettere in
dubbio di poter trovare di nuovo una
persona che sia anche solo simile,
secondo me è sia una fortuna che una
sfortuna. E' una sfortuna perché come avevi
detto tu, effettivamente ti mette
diciamo in quella condizione di insicurezza... e di paura e pensi che non ci sarà di meglio
La fortuna però è anche quella
che ti fa esattamente capire che cosa
vuoi e che cosa non vuoi. Il mio invito è
prima di tutto quello di non disperare
secondo sei molto giovane, non credo che
tu possa aver visto il meglio e il
peggio, ma secondo me non c'è mai fine al
meglio e al peggio
La cosa però che devi capire è che ora hai
una consapevolezza più grande, non ti
accontenterai più, perchè? Perchè hai,
diciamo un'asticella emotiva e interiore
molto più alta, e ci sta stare da soli e
ci sta aspettare e ci sta anche cercare
nel momento in cui si ottiene questa consapevolezza
L'amore è una fortuna secondo me. Io sono
del parere che nell'arco di una vita
ci sono degli innamoramenti no? Nel senso il
primo è l'innamoramento un po' giovanile
un po' che comunque ti fa perdere la
testa, quindi che ti fa anche un po'... sì sì
fantasticare, insomma. Il secondo è quello che
ti fa capire realmente cosa vuoi no? Ti
metti in discussione e metti in discussione.
E il terzo diciamo che potrebbe essere
quello che...
hai scelto, cioè che veramente ti veste e
ti appartiene. Si. Il quarto è quello dopo il
divorzio
Ciao Guglielmo, dato che non sono mai stata abituata a provarci apertamente con una
persona, volevo chiederti un consiglio
riguardo a questo
Come posso conquistare un ragazzo? Grazie se
risponderai e un abbraccio a te e al tuo
ospite. Allora... tacco alto, scollatura vertiginosa.  No scherzo dai
E' una battutaccia. Posso? Vai spara. Scusa non so
perché mi sento cosi pronto oggi, così... Io
sono esattamente come te, io piuttosto
che provarci morirei, mi ammazzerei. Io
credo che sia un pochino come il
paracadutismo. Il primo salto ti
terrorizza, pensi di morire, ma in realtà
quando ti rendi conto poi che alla fine,
sotto sotto, non muori, perché comunque
atterri col paracadute e quello che hai
avuto è semplicemente un brivido di un
momento, fine. Il secondo, il terzo, il
quarto, il quinto, diventano molto più
semplici. All'interno della testa di una
persona che è molto più tranquilla
nell'approcciarsi, c'è anche secondo me
un'analisi molto più tranquilla riguardo
al no.
Cioè se una persona ti dice "Guarda non
sono interessata", non vuol dire che sei
una m***a, vuol dire semplicemente che non c'è un
interesse reciproco, quindi amen! Però
possono essere mille motivazioni . Si
secondo me devi caricare e questo lo
dico anche a me, per quando poi ci dovrò
provare, visto che ormai lui ha già
trovato un'altra persona. Secondo me
bisogna incominciare ad affrontare in
maniera più leggera queste situazioni
perché più tempo si aspetta prima di
aprire bocca e più ci si caricano le
guance di parole, quindi, e di
significati e di pensieri e quindi alla
fine diventa ovviamente più difficile.
Invece riuscire da subito... che ti castrano
magari anche pensieri inutili che ti castrano
e automaticamente non si può. Riuscire da subito
a essere un pochino più trasparenti,
senza però essere creepy. Certo. Non è che devi dire
*versi strani*
Secondo me è un modo anche migliore per
vivere in generale i sì e i no. Sono d'accordo
I gran due di picche. Si. Tu hai beccano due di picche? Io ho
beccato due di picche, certo. Stupido io a non. Ti
prego, eri scioltissimo, eri un brodo di
giuggiole quando mi hai visto la prima volta. Ma per favore! Ciao Gu, allora in realtà io non ho nessuna
relazione strana o situazione assurda,
anzi sono tre anni quasi ormai che sto
insieme alla mia ragazza e... è la persona
più bella del mondo. L' unica cosa è
che vorrei chiederle di sposarmi, ma non so bene come, e magari posso usare te se ti va di
mandare questo vocale e farle sentire,
visto che ti guarda anche lei e che la
vorrei sposare. Abbiamo un messaggio da
Costanza per Giada. Un pò come "C'è posta per te"
Giada tu stai insieme a questa ragazza
che si chiama Costanza da tre anni, tutto
va bene e c'è solamente una cosa che ti
vorrebbe chiedere Costanza
Quindi la domanda è: Giada, mi vuoi sposare? Di di si!
Io faccio un momento di silenzio per
farti prendere...Oddio, non è mai capitata una
cosa così. Oddio...
che bello che è l'amore. Complimenti ragazzi,
congratulazioni. Giada rispondici qua
sotto.
Ti prego si! Metti un commento, incitiamo
ma che co...mh dh sh. Comunque dì di si Giada.
Spero che in questo momento loro abbiano
chiuso il nostro video e stiano facendo
altro o comunque stiano piangendo. Esatto
E se ne stanno infischiando di quello che diremo noi.
Quindi ragazzi meno Costanza e Giada
continuiamo con questo video. Uuu mi ha letto.
Grazie Gu sono emozionatissima, grazie
davvero c'ho stra paura. Te lo credo! Te lo credo! Te lo credo! Fateci sapere come va su
Instagram, qua sotto sul commento fatecelo sapere
Che bella persona che sei. No tu sei
meravigliosa, meriti la felicità
Ok ce la posso fare,
ciao Gu e ciao ospite, innanzitutto volevo farvi i
complimenti per il coraggio di voler
affrontare questo tema, e ovviamente sentirlo e
stressarvi con il mio. Ho lasciato il mio ragazzo dopo tre anni di una relazione
dopo un attacco di panico abbastanza
forte, ma non uno di quelli che ormai
raccontano di avere tutti. No, sono in cura
da una psicologa
seguo una terapia e prendo dei
farmaci. Prima che ti attacchino con
qualche assurdità, sto bene
non è quello il problema, il fatto è che
l'ho lasciato e sono tre mesi che gli ho
chiesto di tornare insieme ma niente
Ancora è indeciso e io non so che fare
perché lo amo e lo aspetterei anche
tutta una vita ma ci sto troppo male.
Non so che fare. Consigli? Penso che quando
dall'altra parte si ha a che fare con una
persona che non riesce a rendersi conto
che molte delle cose che vengono dette,
quando si sta male, spesso non sono per
forza quelle che pensiamo e che si possa
star male senza bisogno di avere
un qualcosa di fisico addosso o dentro il
nostro corpo, manca semplicemente dentro
la nostra testa. Quando ci si
relaziona con una persona così, secondo me ci
si relaziona con una persona che ha paura
dell'ignoto, del dire "Ok, ci diamo una
seconda possibilità e se
poi succede di nuovo e se poi c'è un
qualcosa per cui tu mi lasci, non posso
sapere che cosa sia stato detto, che cosa
non sia stato detto". Tu hai anche la paura che
possa fare il rendersi conto di quanto
un problema possa cambiare una persona. Pesare...possa pesare, esatto
all'interno di una situazione
Io spero veramente che tu possa più che
altro trovare un canale di comunicazione
con questa persona, specialmente perché
sei una persona che si sta aiutando
Affrontando proprio l'argomento e il discorso.
Si assolutamente, e io so quanto possa
essere debilitante, quello che stai
passando, ma non lo possono sapere tutti
Esatto. Cerca di farlo entrare nel tuo
mondo e ti auguro veramente di trovare
le giuste parole.
Già il fatto che in un certo senso lei
comunque si è affidata a persone
competenti che la stanno aiutando è fondamentale
Ah no pensavo a noi due le persone competenti,
scusami nono. Noo, intendo dire...
Che scherzi! Scherzi! Cioè è un gran passone e
quindi secondo me questa roba è da
prendere in considerazione da parte del
ragazzo
Allora mi piace questo tipo, che boh mi piace un sacco
non so come fare per farglielo capire. Ci
conosciamo dalla prima elementare
Abbiamo iniziato a uscire in gruppo
insieme, mi scrive, mi chiede se mi serve
un passaggio. "Ti vengo a prendere io". Non
so se magari si offre sempre lui perché è
gentile o boh. Come c***o faccio? Cioè, come c***o faccio Gu e ospite? Spero siano tutti
i bellissimi fratelli, dovevo dirlo all'inizio
questo, ciao, cosa faccio aiuto?! Che carina
Io ho un'idea,
io sono dell'idea che esiste un tempo
per ogni cosa. Esiste un tempo per
analizzare, un tempo per agire, ma poi nel
momento in cui analizzi troppo esiste
anche un tempo in cui incominciano a
crearsi draghi nella testa delle persone.
Il salto da "Mi ha dato un passaggio" a "mi
ha accompagnata lunedì, martedì,
mercoledì, venerdì, sabato, e incominci a
diventare di colpo un calcolatore e incominci a creare le teorie del
complotto, che i terrapiattisti "Ciao" in
confronto, il mio consiglio è quello
anche di non perder troppo tempo a
creare delle sovrastrutture o a dare
delle motivazioni assurde a dei gesti
che magari sono più semplici. Quindi?
Con tutta la faccia di c**o inizierei ad aprire un
pochino il discorso, per quanto sia
difficile, e il problema è che fra due
mesi tu stai pure a calcolare lo smalto
che si mette alle unghie dei piedi, per
capire se è dello stesso colore dei tuoi
occhi. Perché fidati, esistono storie di
persone che sono state friendzonate una vita
io tra quelli. Si? A me è capitato si. E non avevano mai tirato fuori i loro
sentimenti e quando l'hanno fatto ce
l'hanno fatta. Però è finita... in questo caso
cercavo di darle una spinta, non era modo
per mancarti di rispetto. Cioè
vogliamo ucciderla così? No questo qui è il
messaggio delle persone che dicono
"Complimenti per il tatto". Lui non è gay
vero? Se mette lo smalto dello stesso
colore dei suoi occhi forse si. E' probabile. Se non è gay
allora procedi col piano. Ma anche se è gay
al limite ti dirà "Tesoro se fossi
stato etero ti avrei amata". Ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questa puntata, io
vi ringrazio di cuore per esservi
prestati a questo esperimento e
soprattutto devo dire che personalmente
lo sai che mi è piaciuta tantissimo,
potrebbe essere una delle mie preferite
Fatemi sapere se questa forma di Vita
Buttata, non per forza dal punto di vista
cuore sole, cuore amore, ma di chiacchiera, un
pochino più tranquilla e confidenziale
vi piace e se vi è piaciuta in questo
caso. Fatemi soprattutto sapere se
ascoltando alcune di queste storie avete
dei consigli per i ragazzi e per le
ragazze, delle cose magari alle quali noi non
abbiamo pensato o magari delle cose che
voi pensate in maniera diversa. Insomma
in modo da poter dare anche più... opzioni
più opzioni e più pareri ecco, per chi ci
ha mandato i suoi vocali. Come sempre vi
invito a iscrivervi a questo canale e
attivare le notifiche se non volete
perdervi nessun video.
Ringrazio voi, ringrazio te. Grazie, grazie a voi
E che dire, ci vediamo il prossimo
giovedì, sempre alle 14, con un'altra
puntata di Vita Buttata. Ciaoo
Oh ragazzi comunque, comunque vadano queste cose io voglio aggiornamenti eh